panic buying has been on the rise amid
the global spread of the new coronavirus
store shelves nationwide are dwindling
or totally empty well this is just
unnecessary
on forbes.com Fortune magazine what a
big story about my pizza French oh wait
oh is your is your pizza chain still
operating despite all this unless they
shut us down we will be serving pizza
that's for sure
hi there I'm aria and like many of you
out there I am NOT a fan of the idea of
being infected by the corona virus but
as the World Health Organization
officially declares the corona virus
outbreak as a pandemic there's obviously
a lot of information and misinformation
going around so I want to get to the
bottom of all this for those of us out
there who just want to hunker on down
safely
the panic outside is real we all go
on.that okay okay you know going back
I'm not really scared the carnal virus I
think the the panic is too much I have
no idea if the panic is justified at all
you know we got to be mindful of what's
going on but obviously the craziest
thing is that all the numbers that we
hear are who knows what of it is real on
one of its bull I'm not too worried I
what I heard is that black people are
immune so I'm like I'm part black so I'm
should be fine but 52% of me is worried
its natural of course that during a time
like this for panic to set in but at the
same time unnecessary panic and make
things a lot worse than they actually
are so Jack and I are gonna set out
today to make ourselves a little home
essentials kit based on suggestions by
well vetted sources as well to see how
things are like out there in the wild
there's lot of information and
misinformation in regards to what one
should actually be stocking up with at
home regular household detergent or
disinfectants are good to have in such a
kit as well as hand sanitizer which has
at least 60% alcohol and so I think
those are the three primary things we're
gonna try it by today along with any
other goods my home kit would be a
bottle of tequila I think was a little
bit CBD maybe some chilli napkins for
the girls
girls yes about sanitary amount for
periods yes for period blood yeah I just
hope the Call of Duty servers stay alive
I also want to take a moment actually
clarify the difference between being
self quarantine or practicing social
distancing social distancing is what's
been practiced by a lot of us that are
being told to either work or study from
home but someone who's been told by
medical authorities for any number of
reasons to stay has been self
quarantined but I think what's happening
is that some people get very panicky
about this idea of working or staying
from home and they feel like they need
to stock up on everything
customers are cleaning out store shelves
items like toilet roll hand sanitizer
and pasta are now increasingly hard to
come by you don't have to buy so much
take it easy just relax
it's absolutely ridiculous that so many
people are running out right now to buy
so much extra stuff people are hoarding
toilet paper Stockmann crazy buying a
whole bunch of toilet paper you can
always watch the eyes in the shower I've
even heard some stores are like having
to limit how many people are getting
because I'm sure people are like getting
they're like oh yeah I need 20 can hand
sanitizer bottles because I'm gonna be
locked in my house for three months when
like that's not the case we're put into
the first store I think an office supply
store might be a good bet for hand
sanitizer because they have it for like
school kids and I feel like people are
like going to Target and Walmart for
this they're not thinking about is
supply so this is this was Jack's idea
so let's see what they've done yeah
call the headset patches out of what hit
all the mega rolls
Wow alright well on to the next door
well we had no luck there
oh now we're at a pharmacy
like here either on to the next I posted
a story earlier asking people for any
tips on where we could potentially get
some disinfectant or hand sanitizer
department store we'll check out the
department store Walgreens we'll check a
pharmacy the dark web funny staples
Office Depot a lot of different
suggestions we're gonna keep trying
around la I guess but now it is out of
pharmacy still no luck all disinfectants
and hands and heads are sold out we're
seeing a lot of people walk out with
lots of toilet paper and paper towels
and we're at a supermarket right now
once again everything is sold out
you know the thing is this section here
Assam disinfectants are has hazards this
is paper towels toilet paper that people
have just seems to be stopped me up in
bulk as if we're coming up on an
apocalypse or something so if you're
walking through the bush Serengeti and
you come across the line image become
informed and get it from a credible
source rather than from social media or
your friends or your brother's doctor
we're here at decision pharmacy we did
find this kind of wet tissue which i
think is supposed to become like a
disinfectant but I don't think this
actually would be good because it's not
on a list approved by the EPA I'll put a
link down in the description below of a
list of disinfectants approved by the
EPA that you can buy if you're able to
find them in our front of face masks to
begin with because we should not be and
this isn't even disinfectant or Hannah
this is like people buying out paper
towels paper plates and napkins and
facial tissues also on another note in
the disgusting don't litter
unlike natural disasters where people
stockpile food there is no anticipation
of any type of shutdown of electricity
or water so there's no need to kind of
stock it for it so much product all at
once you know doesn't even last long
whether they just can't chug these
gallons
I guess people want every type of pasta
rotini Eve only comes with food there's
no need to just focus on buying canned
goods because since utilities aren't
expected to be interrupted you can still
buy fresh or frozen food you can meal
prep food delivery may still be an
option for you so there's no need to go
out and stock up a huge amount of food
as if you're going to be going into a
bomb shelter we just spent the whole day
driving around in LA traffic and we
didn't get our hands on any type of
disinfectant detergent or hand
sanitizers but I think one of the
biggest takeaways from this day is
actually just seeing in person how these
stores are just selling out of goods
that may not necessarily even need to be
there's a big difference between being
cautious and preparing accordingly as
well as just panicking and hoarding I
think the only thing you focus on is
having the essentials at home just don't
overdo it you just buy what you need
because hoarding really can put other
people at risk and with a video like
this about a global issue like we're
dealing with information will be
changing and coming at us rapidly over
the course of the next few days weeks
months so all we can do now is just take
things day by day try not to lose our
heads and just support each other
through these times
[Music]
she slices pizza
I'm telling you right now I'm from New
York I know good pizza one of the best
beaches you'll ever taste take it from
me mop guys no food I'm telling you and
I know good pizza slices USA that's the
name